my girl wants me to get veneers but
don't they don't think real yeah don't
they numb they
should file down your hands yeah they
have to fight and what happens then what
happens what happens to your original
teeth
you don't have them they look like
little stops
a great picture go to yfna that's what
it looks like up top
yeah yeah oh you turned into a [ __ ]
and then they put in your uh
go to go to tank go to javonte tank
davis
uh that happened to him no he left in
front i thought
no see that rapper left in front of you
he didn't have to brush him oh you told
me why in that blue cheese dude
went a little bit after no no look at
that picture in the pink right there
in the pink he was hideous before money
oh
yeah yeah that is not 80's real teeth
over there
is that that's what it is that looks
like right before they do the veneers
though yeah
they save it now his teeth are great
that was not ads yeah that is no it is
abs yeah the unibrow and the [ __ ] up
grill and he was still back that is not
real that's real yeah oh i thought oh
like people it doesn't look like
somebody doesn't make happiness
they don't know because he's happy and
he fixes grill
he still rocks the unibrow though which
i appreciate yeah you gotta
it's his thing i love commitment that's
like me rocking my gap i still rock it
damn you have a good gap though yeah
it's good on you yeah that doesn't look
real
yeah that's what i'm saying that does
not look real it looked like his teeth
just like like
what does he look like right now it's
perfect oh he looks so different without
a unibrow i don't like it
yeah i was like the unibrow man yeah
unibrow powder that's fake that's they
trying to that's he got mad
that's not him that's him they like
photoshopped it and made it look more
feminine too i think
look at michael strahan you're talking
about the man that yes that's the man of
gas that's the man against
that first team all gap yeah you gotta
do it but it fits him perfectly yeah he
can't fix that first team all gap
you on the squad you on the squad you
you ain't first team
you got a ways to go before i put you up
there with patrice o'neill and straight
they should pale
so then you got four we need one more
starting five uh chappelle
no no i'm very happy he's four lacey
your honorable mansion dude are you
calling me second string
no that's that's no we wouldn't call you
you got a ways to go dude before you up
there with eddie murphy and trip
and uh [ __ ] the big we put we put
macy gray in this category oh demi
lovato used to have one all right she
did
oh i love that girl yeah oh arnold
schwarzenegger
he does yeah oh hell yeah arnold rocks
is how did we forget about lawrence
phillips yeah lawrence fishburne
mr matrix come on man you know woody
harrelson
yeah he does remember that
is up there okay seal but
he's not first team oh like no no he's
our first team no
no he has he has bigger issues
and i think we know what's going on in
there okay it's been working it's been
crazy we've been in production with
commercials and uh
you know we just opened last weekend a
new black rifle
uh stand-alone store so it's the
drive-through and everything and where's
that grand opening
san antonio so it was their first
stand-alone corporate uh store it was a
pretty cool moment
in a lot of years in the making congrats
man i didn't know that
yeah thank you we would have had a
bigger party invited people down but
obviously we had restrictions as far as
how many people could be there
and then you said you've been in
shooting production what what are you
guys shooting
just commercials you know q4 we're
getting ready to do all of our sale
stuff and all that coming up and so you
know us we're always making some
[ __ ] ridiculous ass commercials i
have nothing to do with coffee but then
we sell
coffee yeah sales got people like oh
they blew up a prius
i'm gonna buy that dark roast like they
did this thing
yeah they did this thing where they
launched the prius and [ __ ]
shot it what'd you guys shoot it with
well without the shooting ones there but
we we
put a uh a minigun from an aircraft on
top of a prius
and had a mini gun on a prius because
why not you know
why we're like little kids sometimes
where we think of these stupid ideas
around a glass of whiskey like we should
put a mini gun
on a prius and then we just do it we're
watching the video right now it looks so
dope
yeah who comes up with the ideas and
then someone like what's the budget on
this thing
like there's no way you guys are hitting
budgets
it's not as much as you think we we were
lucky on that one at least to work with
uh battlefield vegas which is a awesome
kind of
uh shooting facility in las vegas they
had that
weaponry and we worked through some of
the licensing and the things you have to
do to get it functioning
and then we just built the chassis on
the prius we bought the used prius for
like six thousand dollars so i mean
relatively it wasn't that expensive
the project took 160 man hours damn it
looks pretty dope man
you guys have been doing it right though
because you you started out in
uh your headquarters which are still
there but you're not there you guys
we're in
salt lake city right utah
yeah we still have a big present in salt
lake's presence in salt lake city and
then
we have one of the corporate
headquarters here in texas where i'm
based out of and then our tennessee
facility so we're kind of all over
yeah you're all over and so you guys i'm
assuming right now you're not shooting
like new rap videos or anything
which i love i'm such a bad [ __ ]
rapper that i don't think i'm gonna
touch that anymore i think oh i'm so
fun though man i'm gonna start by a fake
country career i've been working on that
one yeah
all right so there's plants there's
plans to bring steelhead trout back to
the la river shut the [ __ ]
up serious this is in the la times
chin's all good news fellas
can you imagine the l.a are you all done
with lies and demise
it's time for some trouble can you
imagine trout in downtown l.a
i brought you the old stuff
listen we're going through the past
present and the future
so let's just put them in the yeah that
whole you know
spillway or whatever you call it dude
whatever you're gonna destroy those fish
i know are they gonna go fishing this
time
yeah fishing literally in the l.a river
you know you've seen you guys drive by
the freeway fish though you know when
people are pissing and tossing needles
into that it is constantly moving though
so
yeah that's true yeah what so it should
be done by 2028.
well look forward to that trout in there
okay that's that you know what steelhead
trout are they're like rainbow trout
yeah yeah we got them in colorado man
yeah they're awesome
is trout better than salmon you think
different tastes
salmons if you like just delicious fatty
fish sam's the way to go
trout is more like what like a little
more gamey white fish right
yeah it has its own yeah it's a white
flesh it has its own taste it's hard to
describe but it's delicious
did you go camping this past weekend the
weekend before
i didn't catch anything i caught a baby
bass
and i caught a few bluegill but then
they got off the hook and then i caught
something else bigger
at the end and then got away all right
yo
i always wonder like i'll be watching
these like fishing like early in the
morning because they come on at five
o'clock when everyone's asleep
yeah and and i respect it of course but
i'll watch it and they like have they'd
be out there for a minute and they
have like 20 pounds and 30 pounds and
they just let they put them in there and
they let them go
what why don't the competition they
usually let them go right oh yeah they
just want to get the weight yeah they
just want to get the weight of them back
out they're just a sport fish you could
eat they're largemouth bass you can eat
them
but that's not something yeah most
people most people don't like
javelinas and hogs and stuff but a lot
of people that go hunting for those
things they don't eat them
oh really yeah what are they just having
a trophy case
yes i'm like no they're the hogs yeah no
yeah i heard who it's talking about i
think maybe tim kennedy's talking about
it they killed
i raised cam haynes on rogue talk about
like it's bad meat
yeah like there's so much better meat
you just kill those things yeah i don't
have it
i don't know oh there's the fish that's
pretty much you hold it down
he's real tiny yes it was like the
smallest thing i've ever caught it's a
beautiful fish
that's a largemouth bass that's smaller
why is it a majestic kind of color to it
it's a cool looking fish and they have
giant mouths so they can actually eat
little baby ducks
they even eat ducks sometimes they're
big enough they eat ducks yeah like
small ducks damn like the ugly duckling
[ __ ] eating him yep
duck yep no not going duck
wait let me try to get this thing flying
next to your faces as close as possible
cover your eyes
hold on we got a little fan i like that
it feels nice they feel great hell yeah
all right all right [ __ ] china
[Music]
jim what model is this it's a dji mavic
mini
i'm gonna send you the one that homeboy
uh asked me to buy
ask you to buy
[Music]
why don't they smell like alcohol does
it really oh i think it's it's
blowing all the alcohol that's my breath
oh
all right good job he's dope yeah all
right
how cool is that damn chin's nice with
it yeah yeah
that's hard see you got too fancy
you got too fast you see what happened
humble yourself there you go there it is
all right good job good job how far can
it go
far really yeah i know real fast with
the battery life
on it like i think like uh it's hard
damn that's
like like maybe how's it going maybe or
less half an hour yeah it's not it's not
i saw some dude when i was out at the
balboa lake
and he was flying over the ducks and
just zoomed in oh
oh it crashed oh yeah in the water they
see his ass out there in the paddle boat
yeah i heard when you start uh using
drones for the first time you get
cheaper ones because you know it's going
to either break it you're going to lose
it yeah
you have a couple i'm still not yeah
that dude who i'm going to hire from
dallas peter
yeah peter he's got a legit drone i'm
sure well he was like hey for the shows
you should get this one
he's like and then you can use it for
whatever you want but i'll send it to
you tell me
he sent me a list of gear that he needs
and you could also
like uh program it to follow you so if
you're on your bike it'll just follow
you as you do the trails oh that's dope
only for half an hour yeah not that long
maybe even less i think it's probably
less oh well that's a complete waste